shereen you were at cowboys training
camp when they started and and ezekiel
didn't show up my theory is they were
they were surprised that elliott didn't
show up and uh totally unexpected that
he did a very good job of making them
think he was going to be there until he
wasn't
yet stephen jones said he was informed
by ezekiel elliott's agent before
training camp started that he wasn't
going to show up but he wouldn't say at
what point he was informed so i think
you're exactly right i think it took him
a little bit by surprise that he didn't
show up
to training camp on time and of course
is still not there is training
down in cabo mexico and you know one
point that that keeps getting looked at
a lot is jerry jones saying you don't
need a rushing champion to win a super
bowl that's true we've seen it many many
times in super bowls but i'll say this
if the dallas cowboys are going to win
the super bowl they're going to have to
have ezekiel elliott period industry
yeah and when that comment came out last
week i mean that that was the point
where it felt like the cowboys initially
were getting their bearings after the
stun and the surprise that elliott did
show up so then they're trying to push
back hey if he's going to push us we're
going to push back so how can we push
back well we can say we don't need to
have the rushing champion well
most teams that when the super bowl have
balance on offense that they can ha they
can have a guy who's capable of being
the russian champion but they don't need
to pound them into the ground because
they have a passing game that
complements the running game and you
have the kind of diversity necessary on
your offense to be a championship team
so i think the broader observation is
it's pretty damn hard to win the super
bowl if you're running the ball so much
that one player ends up leading the
league in rushing i think that's the
truth there the reality is like you said
they need ezekiel elliott and he did i
think a masterful job of making them
think he was content to wait he was
there for all of the offseason program
all of the mandatory mini camp there was
never a word from him he had an issue
with waiting in line behind dak prescott
and amari cooper until he did have an
issue and and skipped out on training
camp and here we are two weeks in he's
still not there and and i don't know
where this ends right we know what he
wants he wants 15 million a year we know
the cowboys now want to go under what
todd gurley got from the rams last year
and used the le'veon bell contract as
the starting point for talks i don't
know how they bridge this gap i don't
know when they bridge this gap sharing
with emmett smith that lasted into the
regular season by two weeks i have a
feeling there's a chance this one could
last into the regular season as well
yeah you know ezekiel has put his cleats
in the ground and they're in there hard
and the cowboys are pushing back and at
this point it's a tug of war and
nobody's winning this tug of war
right now ezekiel remains in mexico and
the cowboys remain without the running
back and they can say all they want hey
we're happy with our rookie running
backs tony pollard mike webber we're
happy with alfred morris we think we can
win with these guys
and reality is their first couple of
games they may be able to win with adam
with against the giants and and
washington but the the larger picture
here is they know they need ezekiel
elliot to win a super bowl if that's
what they're going to do and that's it's
going to put way more pressure on jason
garrett because he's in the final years
contract he knows he needs to get at
least to the nfc championship game and
it's gonna be awfully hard to do that if
he doesn't have ezekiel elliott and you
know they've made the point of a lot of
people made the point that this is like
emmett smith hold out back in the 90s
and it's a little bit like that and he
held out for the first two games the
cowboys win 0-2 and of course he's back
in camp what people don't know is that
jerry didn't go up in his money emmett
just decided to come back he wanted
quarterback money and the cowboys made
him the highest paid running back in
football at some point they're going to
make ezekiel at the highest paid running
back in football
well
as of yesterday it sounded like they're
not inclined to do that or at least
that's the leverage they're trying to do
to maybe get ezekiel to take the same
deal as todd gurley by saying we want to
pay him less than todd gurley we want to
pay him what le'veon bell got maybe
that's the counter to try to get elliot
to just come down to and match the todd
gurley deal but you know another point
on how smart it was for elliot to keep
his cards close to the vest and act like
he was okay without getting a new
contract
if you behave any other way
in february march april may june you
don't draw out from stephen jones
comments like todd gurley's contract is
the starting point you don't draw out
from stephen jones comments like he's
the straw if you will that stirs our
drink they're going to be more guarded
than they otherwise uh were if they know
there's a problem with ezekiel elliott
and i think he did a great job of of
duping them into thinking there wasn't a
problem and and i still think at some
level they're scrambling to get on the
same page sharing because they seem to
be conflicting between st stephen jones
and jerry jones
you know any given day you never know
what they're going to say about this and
it seems like they're all over the place
as they try to settle on a strategy for
dealing with ezekiel elliott
yeah that's the point i was going to
make next is they're all over the place
on this thing one day it's you know this
is what he's got we've done the math and
you know he's under contract with the
fifth year option next year and then we
can use the franchise tag and the the
next day it's it's something else we're
waiting for them to come back to the
negotiating table we're frustrated that
we haven't heard back from them so yeah
it doesn't sound like they're on the
same page and i do think it has to do
with ezekiel elliott really pushing the
issue here they were going to try to
wait till next year to do this deal next
offseason
and he pushed the issue by holding out
now they have to deal with him in
addition to amari cooper and dak
prescott and so now they're trying to
get three three players and trying not
to make them all market setters at their
positions
and and you know that's the best point
that either of us has made all day the
idea that the cowboys wanted to do no
contract with ezekiel this year they
wanted to wait until next year and then
next year who knows what happens and and
there was that specter of demarco murray
that was looming over this the entire
time that maybe you just finished your
contract in your last year with the team
you set a franchise single season
rushing record you lead the league in
rushing and the team says thanks for
everything see you later have fun in
philadelphia so i i think ezekiel
doesn't want to hit the market he
doesn't want to wait that long he wants
to get paid while he still has full
tread on the tires and is still able to
generate the kind of impact that we've
seen from him uh throughout the first
three seasons of his
career all right let's shift to dak
prescott because this is the guy we
thought would be the next one to be paid
by the dallas cowboys i've never gotten
the impression that dak prescott is
inclined to give a hometown discount is
inclined to put any value on the fact
that he is the cowboys quarterback he
wants what he wants regardless of who he
plays for and i feel like there's still
a significant gap between the cowboys in
between prescott
yeah you know stephen jones said
yesterday that they've all given them
top five deals now we don't know it's
unclear what top five what are we
talking about new money uh average we
don't know but
dak prescott is not going to give a
hometown discount it does not sound like
he's made that perfectly clear in the
off season he's talked about hey tom
brady gives the hometown discount
because his wife makes more than he does
i'm not inclined to do that so he is
going to have to get top money the
question is how high do you go with him
how do you rate him in that top five of
quarterbacks based on salary and it's a
tough question and what's he going to
land on what figure does he have in mind
and i do think there is a significant
gap where they are right now
yeah and you know the the bigger picture
point that jerry made last week i was
stephen actually the idea that that not
just the quarterback but all of these
players
need to recognize that there's value in
being a member of the cowboys now i
could make that argument as it relates
to the quarterback but i don't know that
it trickles down to
running back receiver defense offensive
line and i think this is just the best
thing they can come up with to justify
not making these guys the highest paid
players or close to it at their
positions but i i just don't think this
is gonna this idea is gonna fly that
that you have to give up some money
because you're playing for the cowboys
and there's something about that that
has value over and above what it would
be worth to play for any other team
yeah you know what demarcus lawrence did
in his meeting with jerry jones and
steven jones he told him it's not my
job to manage your salary cap and and
stephen jones said you know what you're
right they're going to try to get their
money regardless they don't care what
the cowboys salary cap problems are in
putting a team together they all want to
be highest paid at their positions and
therein lies the problem for the cowboys
is how do you do these three big money
deals for skilled position players and
still have a cap where you can have a
legitimate contending football team it's
hard to do
when you don't when you have three
players getting so much money i think
the atlanta falcons are going through
the same thing right now with so few
players taking up so much room of the
cap
and and demarcus lawrence's position
that's the peyton manning darrell rivas
mindset
i need to get what i can get and it's up
to you to manage your salary cap and
that's the challenge that the cowboys
are going to have you know we haven't
talked about amari cooper i i think
amari cooper is in the best position any
of these guys first of all he's making
13.9 million this year in the fifth year
of his rookie contract zeke is making
three and dak is making two and here's a
mario 13.9 he can afford to sit back and
wait i think he knows just by watching
what's happening with dak prescott and
there should be coordination between the
two camps because if neither guy does a
deal you can only franchise tag one of
them the other guy is going to get to
the open market possibly with a
transition tag because if there's no new
cba there would be a franchise tag and a
transition tag available for all teams
next year but still you're going to get
the chance to go to the market and get
top dollar and i think amari cooper
realizes that of those three guys he's
got the best chance of walking out the
door and cashing in somewhere else
yeah there's no question about that i
talked to amari for a long time one day
and uh he made the point that he's
different from melvin gordon and ezekiel
elliott because of that 13 million he's
making this season he said it's
different at the running back position
they just don't make that much money but
i'm in good shape he is in good shape
he's in good shape whether the cowboys
sign him now or whether the cowboys sign
him at the end of the season or he hits
the free agent market or he gets a
franchise tag whatever happens with
amari cooper he's sitting pretty there's
no question about that
yeah and you know it's hard to imagine
all three of those guys sticking around
that's the challenge for jerry jones and
stephen jones can they come up with a
way to hold these three guys together
and then
put more around them enough around them
and what it comes down to if you're
gonna have a nucleus of highly paid
players you're going to sacrifice when
it comes to depth that's what the
patriots do with all the cap space that
tom brady leaves behind they have a
second class a middle class a second
tier of guys who can come in and play
when needed for a lot of these other
teams when somebody gets injured you're
rolling the dice with an undrafted free
agent shireen and you're just hoping for
the best
yeah and they're already looking ahead
the contracts that expire after this
season lyell collins they're starting
right tackle you know they drafted
connor mcgovern to replace him next year
they're not going to be able to resign
lyal collins and then you look at byron
jones you know pro bowl cornerback last
season they're probably not going to be
able to resign byron jones they want to
but they've prepared with that by
drafting corners over the last couple
years but some of these guys that they
really want to keep they're going to
have to let walk away because they're
just not going to have the room to do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports